soon ill and his friends have been using
a group messaging app for over a year to
chat with each other he suspects that on
average they send each other more than
100 messages per day sudol takes a
random sample of seven days from their
chat history and records how many
messages were sent on those days the
sample data are strongly skewed to the
right with a mean of 125 messages and a
standard deviation of 44 messages he
wants to use these sample data to
conduct a t-test about the mean which
conditions performed for performing this
type of significance tests have been met
so let's just think about what's going
on here soon l might have some type of a
null hypothesis maybe he got this
hundred maybe he read a magazine article
says that on average the average teen
agers sends a hundred text messages per
day and so maybe the null hypothesis is
that the mean amount of messages per day
that he and his friends send which was
signified by mu maybe the null is 100
that they're no different than all other
teenagers and maybe he suspects and
actually they say it right over here his
alternative hypothesis would be what he
suspects that they spend they'd send
more than 100 text messages per day and
so what he does is he takes a sample
from the population of days and there's
over 365 they say they've been using the
group messaging app for over a year and
he takes seven of those days so n is
equal to seven and from that he
calculates sample statistics he
calculates the sample mean which is
trying to estimate the true population
mean right over here and he also is able
to calculate a sample standard deviation
and what you do in a significance test
is you say well what is the probability
of getting this sample mean or something
even more extreme assuming the null
hypothesis and if that probability is
below a preset threshold then you would
reject the null hypothesis and it would
suggest the alternative but in order to
feel good about that significance test
and be able to
even calculate that p-value with
confidence there are conditions for
performing this type of significance
test the first is is that this is truly
a random sample and that's known as the
random condition and you have seen this
before when we did significance tests
with proportions here we're doing it
with means population mean sample mean
in the past we did it with population
proportion and sample proportion
well the random condition it says it
right here Sunol takes a random sample
of seven days from their chat history
they don't say how he did it but we'll
just take their word for it that it was
a random sample the next condition is
sometimes known as the independence
independence condition and that's that
the individual observations in our
sample are roughly independent one way
that they would be independent for sure
is if Sunil is sampling with a
replacement they don't say that but
another condition so you either could
have replacement sampling with
replacement or another way where you
could feel that it's roughly independent
is if your sample size is less than or
equal to 10% of the population now in
this situation he took 7 he took a
sample size of 7 and then the population
of days they says that they've been
using the group messaging app for over a
year so they've been using it for over
365 days so 7 is for sure less than or
equal to 10% of 365 which would be 36
point 5 so we meet this condition which
allows us to meet the independence
condition now the last condition is
often known as the normal condition and
this is to feel good that the sampling
distribution of the sample means right
over here is approximately normal and
this is going to be a little bit
different than what we saw with
significance test when we dealt with
proportions there's a few ways to feel
good that the sampling distribution of
the sample means is normal
one is is if the underlying parent
population normal so parent parent
population normal now they don't tell us
anything
that there's actually a a normal
distribution for the amount of time that
they spend on a given day so we don't
know this one for sure but sometimes you
might another way is to feel good that
our sample size is greater than or equal
to 30 and this comes from the central
limit theorem that then our sampling
distribution is going to be roughly
normal but we see very clearly our
sample size is not greater than or equal
to 30 so we don't meet that constraint
either now the third way that we could
feel good that our sampling distribution
of our sample mean is roughly normal is
if our sample is if our sample is
symmetric symmetric and there are no
outliers or maybe even you'd say no
significant outliers now is this the
case well it says right over here the
sample data are strongly skewed to the
right with a mean of 125 messages in a
standard deviation of 44 messages so
this strongly Q skewed to the right it's
clearly not a symmetric sample data and
so we don't meet any of these can any of
these sub conditions for the normal
condition and so we do not meet the
normal condition for our significance
test